dave i will start with you
being the one who gets murdered in a
murder mystery is such an honor do you
wear it as a badge of honor
absolutely yeah
yeah i mean it's like i get killed in
the first minute of the show but then
they're all talking about me the rest of
the time it's an honor it is a dream job
you get to not be there but they're
talking about you non-stop it's like
here we go
uh and uh like the way that this show is
told it's everybody's different
perspective in a different episode did
you have a favorite is somebody's story
was that your favorite of one of the
episodes
um i did like that one a a lot um
you know
if i was to pick a favorite episode i
will say
i i'm not rubbing it in because i know
they haven't shown you yet the last
episode is awesome like he the way he
brings us all home is just incredible um
but i would say stylistically if we're
looking at all the genres that we
display for me an action movie is
absolutely the one i would i would do i
would absolutely watch like under siege
2
over any other
one of these movies so
your favorite episode is is your episode
okay
and
they paid me the most for that
i i get paid by the line i have a very
strangely structured deal
but we don't talk about it
and uh zoey what was it like just
obviously shooting this looked like a
whole hell of a lot of fun but when you
guys weren't shooting did you all hang
out like this seemed to me like a
bonding experience as well as shooting a
fantastic television show yeah
we were it really really was
um also considering
the time that we got to shoot this it it
was the height of kovid in the u.s and
um
it was uh up for a lot of us the first
time we were coming back to work
and it
in a lot of ways felt like this
just a fam i mean we all bonded so
quickly and we would eat our our
hot snacks together outside and
we didn't really go back to our trailers
um
we just we hung out a ton when we were
there you know and it it
i we would go home and my face would be
hurting from just laughing so hard you
see raj we used to have actors used to
have a very glamorous thing going where
you could sit around in your trailer and
people would bring you food you could
just eat and stuff and then
this is more like
oh i can't wait for the scene to be over
i'm going to go outside and take a sip
of water and then come back in you know
what i mean like all
all the fun and glitz and glamour is
like removed from it in the post-cold
world
and yet despite all that eating you know
tamales underneath like a seven thousand
pound industrial
uh uh ac unit um in the freezing cold um
we still managed to have like an
insanely good time is uh is xavier based
off anyone or any combination of people
in particular or will we never know
you'll definitely never know uh it's
it's a character that um
is is not the most likable and so
they're the uh i don't want to offend
anyone but also like
uh yes they're they're like elements i
took from watching interviews of people
maybe but uh it's definitely an
amalgamation um but again in my mind i
think it's uh uh it's a it's a lovely
homage to these people whose interviews
i watched um but some people might take
it the wrong way and i get that
okay and uh which one of you is the
xavier which one of you is the most
famous person from their graduating
class
um
me
go for it go forward
this is how
stupid everything is where it's like i
have people i graduated in my high
school class with who are
neuroscientists my friend is a doctor
she's been like working in trauma during
kovid like every day
for like
two years straight like these great
geniuses and i'm looking for a shout out
what's your name uh dr theresa sullivan
uh truly like an amazing hero but yet
i'm like i want her to be the most
famous famous person from your class
yeah but guess what unfortunately for
her she can't make she can't perfectly
execute and land a joke where her
character
pants like
and that is why when we go back home
give her a chance strangers will buy me
drinks and not her so i got you theresa
uh and before i let you go quickly zoe
i'll start with you um finish this
sentence in my graduating class i would
have been voted most likely to what
um
[Music]
oh
most likely to um
i've said that already he did that
already
to finish my homework on time
all right there you go rebel child
me
yep
oh
god most likely
no
i don't know
i don't know i like you go and then let
me think um most likely uh
to
um
make a career out of spending most of
his time watching good fellas uh oh wow
that's very specific
that's very specific honestly
most most like most likely to honestly
not be a performer in any way like i was
a shy kid in high school i had no
intentions of doing any of this and so
uh yeah that's that's what i wanted
uh you guys are amazing the show is so
much fun congratulations on everything
really appreciate you awesome ross
brother take care thanks man take it
easy guys bye